if it turns out that the beauty that is
consciousness in the universe is bigger
than just humans the AI can carry that
same flame
forward does it scare you or are you
concerned that AI will replace humans so
during my career I had a moment where I
realized that you know maybe we need to
offload to machine means to truly
understand the universe around us right
instead of just having humans with pen
and paper solve it all and to me that
sort of process of letting go of a bit
of
agency gave us way more leverage to
understand the world around us a quantum
computer is much better than a human to
understand matter at the at the Nano
scale similarly I think that Humanity
has a choice do we accept the
opportunity to have intellectual and
operational leverage that AI will unlock
and thus ensure that we're taking along
this path of growth in scope and scale
of civilization we may dilute ourselves
right uh there might be a lot of workers
that are AI but overall out of our own
self-interest by combining and
augmenting ourselves with AI uh we're
going to achieve much higher growth and
much more Prosperity right to me I think
that the most likely future is one where
humans augment themselves with AI I
think we're already on this path to
augmentation we have phones we use for
communication we have on ourselves at
all times we have wearables soon that
have shared perception with us right
like the human ey pin or I mean
technically your Tesla car has shared
perception and so if you have shared
experience shared context you
communicate with one
another and you have some sort of IO
really it's an extension of
yourself um and to me I think
that Humanity augmenting itself with AI
and having AI that is not
anchored to anything biological both
will
coexist and the way to align the parties
we already have a sort of mechanism to
align super intelligences that are made
of humans and Technology right companies
are sort of large mixture of expert
models where we have neural routing of
tasks within a company and we have ways
of economic exchange to align these
behemoths and to me I think
capitalism is the way and I do think
that whatever configuration of matter or
information leads to maximal growth will
be where we converge just from like
physical
principles and so we can either align
ourselves to that reality and and join
the acceleration up in scope and scale
of
civilization or we can get left behind
and try to decelerate and move back in
the the forest let go of
technology and return to our primitive
State and those are the two paths
forward at least to me but there's a
philosophical question whether there's a
limit to the human capacity to align so
let me bring it up as a form of argument
this guy named Dan
Hendrick and he wrote that he agrees
with you that AI development can be
viewed as an evolutionary
process but to him to Dan this is not a
good thing as he argues that natural
selection favors AIS over humans and
this could lead to human extinction what
do you think if it is an evolutionary
process and AI
systems
may have no need for
humans I do think that we're actually
inducing an evolutionary process on the
space of AIS through the market right
right now we run AIS that have positive
utility to humans and that induces a
selective pressure if you consider a
neural net being alive when there's a an
API running instances of it on gpus
right and which apis get run the ones
that have high utility to us right so
similar to how we domesticated wolves in
term turn them into dogs that are very
clear in their expression they're very
aligned right uh I think there's going
to be an opportunity to steer uh Ai and
Achieve uh highly aligned Ai and I think
that humans plus AI is a very powerful
combination and it's not clear to me
that pure AI um would select out that
combination so the humans are creating
the election pressure right now to
create AIS that are aligned to humans
but you know given how AI develops and
how quickly it can grow and
scale one of the concerns to me one of
the concerns is unintended consequences
like humans are not able to anticipate
all the consequences of this process the
scale of damage that can be done through
unintended consequences with AI systems
is very large the scale of the upside
yes right by augmenting ourselves with
AI is UN unimaginable right now the the
opportunity cost we're we're at a fork
in the road right whether we take the
path of creating these Technologies
augment ourselves and get to climb up
the Carter scale become multiplanetary
with the Ada of AI or we have a hard cut
off of like we don't birth these
Technologies at all and then we leave
all the potential upside on the table
Yeah right and to me out of
responsibility to the future humans we
could carry right with higher carrying
capacity by scaling up civilization out
of responsibility to those humans I
think we have to make the greater
grander future happen is there a middle
ground between cut off and all systems
go is there some argument for
caution I think like I said the market
will exhibit caution every organism
company
consumer is acting out of self-interest
and they won't assign Capital to things
that have negative utility to them the
problem is with the market is like you
know there's not always perfect
information there's manipulation there's
a bad faith actors that mess with the
system it's not it's not always
a um rational and honest system well
that's why we need Freedom of
Information freedom of speech and
freedom of thought in order to converge
be able to converge on uh the Subspace
of technologies that have positive
utility for us
all